there's no time for me to look back or
look ahead it's there's so much going on
and um
you know I've enjoyed every minute of it
and you know I still want to keep
playing
and uh
you know after this game you know I'll
probably take a week or two off and then
get back to work so I'd love to
you know do that after winning the game
that'd be make the off season obviously
a lot more enjoyable
on the football field he was as
dedicated as any player as a teammate
he's as good a teammate as you could
have
he took it upon himself to work really
hard and now you see the final result
he was so annoyed that he got taken so
late in the draft he wants to prove the
198 guys ahead and weren't as good as
him
they were expecting that he'd be a solid
quarterback and maybe even a very good
quarterback someday but he exceeded all
their expectations
but he throws an incomplete pass he goes
nuts somebody runs the wrong route
he goes nuts
the guy's down by 25 points in the
second half and you still think it's Tom
Brady that's not completely over that's
why you play to the end it's 60 Minute
game and we're disappointed in the way
we played and knew that we could go out
and do a lot better in the second half
Tom's next game isn't against the
opponent it's against the critics heat
meets Bob Kraft the owner of the New
England Patriots and he says I'm the
best decision this franchise has ever
made just think about that see he's the
most hated quarterback why
because he's the best quarterback
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
there is a similarity between throwing a
football and throwing a baseball a lot
of the the arm action is the same the
the body position the the use of leg
your legs is the same there's just a
little bit difference in the delivery
the actual ball coming out of the hand
is a little different because the
baseball you're on the top the football
you're on the side but Tommy's throwing
ability he threw both balls great he's
one of the best catchers I've had at
throwing
throwing the ball
I mean he was a big strong guy he's a
left-handed hitter he had power he'd hit
home runs I think he would have had
power in professional baseball
um he he was a good hitter for average
probably his only only downfall was he
didn't run real well and um and he's
actually gotten better at that
my connection with uh Tom Brady as he
played JV football here for me as some
other sports and his family they not too
far from the high school here
parents are very involved in his life
they they keep away from the sports but
they're very influential to him at the
same time they make sure Tommy does the
right things works hard and is very
respectful of his coaches so that in
itself
told me something about the family it's
like oh I don't have to worry about
parents
his dad was an athlete his sisters were
uh
college softball pitcher one of the best
in the nation his other sisters I
believe were soccer players all at top
ranked colleges and Tommy being the baby
of the family was around the ball a
football dad was baseball always
something in his hands at all time he
would always loved to talk about his
sisters
there he's the youngest of four but he
was a pretty simple guy he was in the
sports and his family there wasn't a lot
of other stuff
[Music]
would he have succeeded in the Major
League Baseball adult question he played
against Eric bakkich the Michigan
baseball coach they were high school
Rivals their teams and they played
against each other in high school yeah
Tommy was Tommy was a legit MLB Prospect
without question I think Tom Brady would
have potentially been a major league
catcher I think he had that kind of
ability but to forecast that Tom Brady
would have become as great in baseball
as he did in football you can't do
because he would have had to become the
greatest player of all time in baseball
and that as good as he was that would
have been a long shot
so when you see something special come
through you're sort of just pointed it
and go huh I think we could do something
with that and he was a kid because as
Tom is he's slow in feet
but he works at it
and he has a good mind for the game and
he really worked on destroying mechanics
and he threw a very nice ball he played
catcher in baseball and he was what I
thought he would actually play but he
kept pursuing football and I guess that
one paid off a little bit for him and
I'm not a really reactive athlete you
know people have seen me play for a long
time I like to really anticipate things
when I'm out there
not sure if we've ever done a high
school football game in our five years
where you could say that
yeah it's very impressive thus far for
both these teams both teams have played
an excellent ball game and it's not done
yet
I was really impressed when I saw him in
person face to face because I was
shocked how big he is
you know I always thought that he is you
know my size maybe one meter 88
something like that not that muscular
but if you see him in person on the
field with cleats on shoulder pads and
helmet he is not a small guy I think a
lot of people don't realize that he is I
think he is six four one meter 93 he is
bigger than a lot of people think
[Music]
I was the first guy to believe in Tom
so I said hey I got someone who can play
quarterback hey he's intelligent I can
do some special things and I worked hard
with Tommy whenever he wanted that extra
time I gave him the extra time I think
that was it just the belief in him
positive coaching and then also just see
extra work when he wanted it
already
too Kirby at 25
1 he said he really wanted to be a
quarterback
and when that guy puts his mind to
something
pretty driven so he always goes the
extra mile uh doing the extra work
to try to perfect whatever he's doing
even at that age you got to put the work
in you got to listen you got to be be
humble enough to learn
um you know you can't think you know
everything you got you know it's
football's too difficult of the game and
there's too much
it's not an individual sport it's a
coordination between a lot of different
people
[Applause]
[Music]
Kirby out to the 36 yard line it's going
to be just short of a first down pickup
of nine no in high school we were really
good friends on the football field Tom
and I actually created our own plays
back then we created a signal to where
he would look out and check out the
defense he would pull his face mask and
for me to acknowledge it back I would
pull up my left sock and then we knew
that he was going to throw me the pass
on that play you can definitely see him
improvised from time to time and you
know his famous quarterback sneak where
he goes over the top that's kind of a
play that he'll just call and not even
let the other linemen know so yeah I see
that all the time and it's really
awesome to hear his Cadence or to hear
him on TV when he's saying red 35 Red 35
and it's funny art you know I used to be
on this field hearing that same voice
all the time so it's it's very very
familiar
[Applause]
[Music]
land a few looks it and he takes it
Kirby
at the 45 a pick above 11. and a first
down
I we couldn't have anybody film for us
uh The Varsity did but not the lower
level and they they would get the films
and they'd be watching film other games
uh I'd be watching films of other teens
but they're watching themselves and
critiquing themselves and then I'm sure
they bring it home and you know Tom
senior is doing it and back in the early
90s there wasn't a lot of football film
study especially in high school and Tom
brought it on himself with myself and
the other receivers that every Sunday
we'd play on either Friday or Saturday
every Sunday we'd go to his house for
lunch me him and the other receivers his
mom would make us you know sandwiches
we'd sit down and analyze the film
[Music]
we're ready to throw Kirby with a great
catch over the shoulder
at the 35.
um sprinkler gate was our um our
sophomore year championship when Tommy
was his first year as a starter and my
first year as a starting receiver we
went down to play Bellarmine for the
league championship we were driving for
the winning touchdown go ahead touchdown
and it was 6 p.m because our game had
gone so long and at 6 PM back then the
sprinklers came on so we had to wait
about 15 minutes for them to you know
clear everything up sprinklers go down
you start driving down the field
sprinklers come on again have to stop it
again get the ball back the ball's wet
Tommy drops back throws a swing to our
running back he fumbles they pick it up
and take it to the house and I swear to
this day Bellarmine turned those
sprinklers on on purpose
[Music]
thank you
I think the fact that Tom Brady was a
really good recruit when he came to
Michigan people expected him to be a
good player
they never expected him to be a great
player and that's what he became in my
book about Greg Hardin the counselor at
Michigan who worked with our athlete Tom
Brady walked into his office one day and
said one of the guys on the team said
you can help me you know I want to be
the starter at Michigan I'm not there
I'm I'm way down on the depth chart and
Greg Hardin got Tom Brady to believe in
himself in their conversations
to the point where he was able to
perform at a high level
Tom Brady kind of becoming an
afterthought
[Applause]
you know Tom Brady and Drew Brees
played against each other in college in
1999 like everybody talks about their
Pro careers but 1999 Tom Brady and
Michigan was
number four in the country and Purdue
was number 11 in the country in 1999
and Tom Brady in michigan won 38-12 and
that was the first time that those guys
played
you know that's phenomenal the two guys
both lasted for over 20 years in the
game of football and became you know
perhaps the two most accomplished
statistical quarterbacks of all time
[Applause]
foreign was
LeBron James and Tom Brady
level high school player he was the best
high school player in baseball and
football in the United States he won
them both in USA Today and Drew is from
Brighton Michigan which is about 20
minutes outside of Ann Arbor he was the
biggest recruit probably in the history
of Michigan football
he came here to Michigan great talent
great friend of mine great guy and he
was Chiefs he was supposed to be the
Michigan quarterback in 98 and 99. and
there was one problem
there was one person
in Ann Arbor who didn't think the Drew
Hansen should be the quarterback
Thomas Edward Brady didn't think Drew
Henson should be the quarterback
the Syracuse
game in 1998 was one of the worst
experiences I've ever had
at Michigan I was with the team for
almost six years
we had lost the first game Notre Dame
we lost the Syracuse game whole team had
played bad and the fans turned on Tom
and they were bullying and they wanted
Drew Hansen to play it was very bad I
was afraid he was going to leave I
thought he was going to transfer it was
very bad I thought Drew Henson was going
to be the quarterback from heading
forward
and I just let Tom know I believe that
I'm
and we're gonna rally
and he's got to keep fighting and I
believed in him
we played basketball together in Murrell
basketball together
and we're playing this frat guys frat
guys and they're making fun of Tom
because of Drew Henson
and the game's over we're about to win
we're up by 20 points and Tommy looks at
me
says beef how many fouls do I have
and Tommy's got two followers you're
allowed for and he said next time you
bring the ball up to court
Sprint up the court
and don't look back whatever you did
get the ball Sprint up the court all the
sudden here up splat
Tommy elbowed the guy that was making
fun of him the whole game and like
knocked the kid off
that's like Tom Brady today moment in
1999. Polaris
just I was offering to beat this kid up
the whole game Tom's like Steve don't
worry about it just
classic classic Tom Brady
cleans up his own mess as he would like
to say
by the time he left Michigan he had a
great Orange Bowl game where he threw
for 369 yards and five touchdowns that
was his last college game beat Alabama
in overtime
and that's the game that put him on the
map
simply by that he's a role model to a
lot of people somebody by being an NFL
player and becoming one making that
transition from college to the NFL opens
a lot of doors and dreams for the Youth
but then being as successful as he was
his work ethic his continuous he had a
drive to win there's a lot of things
that we can learn from from that man
and I remember when we drafted him back
in 2000 I mean he had a chip on his
shoulder because he was so annoyed that
he got taken so late in the draft got
taken in the sixth round 199th player
I think Tom Brady definitely had to have
a chip on his shoulder as a six or under
half pick it's like that's all they
think of me you know knowing that he
closed out his college career so
strongly he probably didn't expect to be
a first round draft pick but he might
have been thinking I'll go in the second
ah the third round and then tick tick
tick sixth round you go and it's like
I've got I've got some people to prove
some things too
I think if Tom wasn't drafted in the
sixth round or drafted 199 it would have
changed a lot of things
because what makes Tom
so successful he wants to prove the 198
guys ahead and weren't as good as him
when Tom Brady got drafted by the
Patriots that was the Pro Football
editor The Tampa Tribune and and and and
I'm paying attention to who the Bucks
are drafting but more more than anything
I'm actually where are my boys going the
guys I covered at Michigan and when I
saw that he went there I knew it was a
winning program and that that would be
good but I also knew that Drew Bledsoe
was a quarterback and that wasn't that
good however as a sixth round draft pick
you'd figure Tom it needed a couple of
years to kind of get his feet on the
ground and be ready to be a starter you
know so it seemed like a good situation
for Tom to go to New England he was so
excited I told him I was excited for him
he was going to my team the Patriots and
he was getting ready to hang up on me
and he said something pretty damn funny
he knows I love Drew Bledsoe
and of course Tom Brady being Tom Brady
says beef I'm going to take bledsoe's
job
the thing that amazed me about Tom Brady
is he's a sixth round draft pick those
guys are marginal they might not even
make the team and he meets Bob Kraft the
owner of the New England Patriots and he
says I'm the best decision this
franchise has ever made
just think about that
you know I mean here's a guy who was a
pretty good quarterback at Michigan who
goes sixth round of the draft and that's
what he tells the owner and he made good
on it
I was happy
and Brady made the Patriots
I felt sorry for Drew Bledsoe but when
that went down we had a few of the other
coaches around and we were so excited
he's in the game look at I don't get
he's made it to the pros and it just
escalated from there
Dad can't really see your heart you know
and there's so many free agents so many
late round draft picks who had amazing
Hall of Fame careers because one thing
you can never measure or see is the
heart really and he I think he's one of
those players with just the Eternal the
non-stop drive for you to become the
best to be better than you were
yesterday
Brady being drafted in the sixth round
he can name the quarterbacks that went
before him every one of them seen him do
it plenty of times
for him Brady is like you're you're good
but you're not good enough to be the man
you know so I think for him getting
drafted in the sixth round and every
quarterback going before him
that just gave him the motivation that
he took you know to go out and try to
prove that he can play this game at a
high level
[Music]
I think you know when I think of Bill
Belichick I think of toughness
and and he demands that of his players
toughness and loyalty and playing the
game the right way and and being the 12
month a year player I think that you
know he's he's an old school football
coach not just because he's an older guy
you know I think he's made good
contributions to the game anybody who
wins the number of Super Bowls he's won
has to be a solid coach I don't know
that he had a huge impact on Tom Brady I
think he had some impact on Tom Brady
but not a huge impact
I think Bill did a really good job back
in in 2001 on August 5th
of that year the court the guy who was
just coaching quarterbacks close friend
of mine by the name of Dick raybein died
[Music]
okay he died in training camp
on a day off we had a day off in
training camp and he was running on a
treadmill and passed out on a treadmill
then I talked to him that day and he was
fine and he was going to get a a stress
test the next day and had the stress
testing he he dropped he was dead
and Belichick and I sat down and we
decided that we would handle the
quarterback position just ourselves so I
think even back then starting all the
way back in 2001 I mean I think he's had
a very very big positive influence on
Tommy
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm from New Jersey and has you know
growing up in New Jersey even though
Tommy was kind of cocky he knew not to
get carried away I mean we had one
instance in practice where Tommy threw
the ball to the wrong guy
it was a completion
okay they caught it but you know certain
plays are designed to go to a certain
spot and he didn't throw it to the right
spot so I looked at him and I said why'd
you throw it there
and he goes well I said where are you
supposed to go versus that coverage
where's the ball supposed to go and he
goes well it's really supposed to go to
the tight end they go was it tight end
up he goes I don't know I didn't look at
him I said why didn't you look at him
and he goes well because you know I
threw it back there
so I took off my my whistle around my
neck and I threw it at him and he goes
what I said you might as well call the
place I mean if you're not going to
listen to me I mean you know I'm the one
supposed to be calling the place now
you're calling the place so you know for
the next few years we no longer had that
argument
[Music]
he actually was our fourth string
quarterback that whole year
you know most teams in the league keep
three
we kept him because we saw something in
him it wasn't anywhere near ready you
know he used that year to get himself
his body ready and his mind ready and
you know by the end of that first year
the first year only through three passes
he had one completion it was one for
three his first year in a league Brady
had already been
in New England a year before I got there
you know they drafted him in 2000 I got
that in 2001.
but
Drew Bledsoe was the man
Drew Bledsoe had just signed a contract
to come just became the first 100
million dollar quarterback
and so it's Drew's team and nobody could
have fathom Drew browitzer was the
highest paid player in the NFL at that
time and it really top-notch quarterback
and the fact that Tom Brady
took the job when he got a chance and
and never looked back that I think
that's the most phenomenal thing that
and you think what if Drew Bledsoe had
never gotten hurt and what if Tom Brady
had backed him up for three years and
what if he you know sort of atrophied or
something like you know in his career
and never really got the chance to be
Tom Brady but a lot of you know when a
guy becomes great they need to really
want it which Tom obviously wants it as
badly as anybody still does
until he get a full grasp
of the offense and of the Playbook
because he's just getting thrown in
they had to Lean on Me at you know
Antoine in the running game until we
slowly broke Tommy alone in the Playbook
and as you can see it each game
he's getting better and better in the
passing game he's getting more familiar
he's getting you know I'm saying he's
getting more comfortable
in the place that's being called and you
can see and
see it he's a very fiery guy
Tommy needed to be on the Patriots and
learn from
Bill Belichick and Charlie Weiss and
Dick rabine and and Drew Bledsoe would
you asked me if Tom if Tom would be what
he was if Drew Bonsall didn't get hurt I
don't believe so but there's a second
part to that that's very important that
nobody talks about Tom won the second
quarter the backup quarterback job in
the off season in 2001 from Damian York
and if he didn't work hard and win that
job you would not know who he is you
would not be interviewing me right now
as they say
one man's trash another man's treasure
he was in a fight for the backup
quarterback with a guy that we had just
picked up from the Dolphins by the name
of Damon youward and at the end of
training camp bill and I sat down and we
picked Tommy by this much it wasn't like
he beat him out by a lot and when
Bledsoe got hurt early in the year and
Tommy went in we took baby steps we
didn't get too wild we didn't throw the
ball all over the place
we've kind of took steps and let the
offense grow as the year went on and
grow it did because by the end of that
year you know we're in a two-minute
drive to win the Super Bowl with Tommy
at the helm and next thing you know
confetti's all over the place and we
just won the Super Bowl that was Super
Bowl 36.
Super Bowl Sunday
if you plan in it you're a wreck
first of all the night before seemed
like the longest night you you have
plays going over in your head you don't
want to make a mistake
you could dream about making a big play
because you also dream about you you
really don't get no productive rest
and you wake up that morning about
6 a.m you go to breakfast
you know the Super Bowl is played later
on that evening so you got another long
day anticipating waiting for it to
happen and it just you just kill
yourself beat yourself up you just you
can't you can't rest these you just want
to get to the stadium and get that first
lick so you can get the butterflies out
your stomach so do you know that you're
ready to play ball
[Applause]
his biggest moment ever was Super Bowl
36.
where he hit Troy Brown we had four wide
receivers on a field it was a tie ball
game
bulletin was like defense you have to be
physical on the receivers because they
did a fast little receivers get in and
out and he was like on the offensive
side
Antoine
we got to run you we got to play uh ball
control game we got to slow the game
down for them to keep the offense if our
officers on the field that means that
offense is on the bench and that's what
we want to do slow them down
they had all the momentum there was a
little over a minute to go okay we had
no timeouts and we're playing with this
inexperienced quarterback a second year
guy his first year playing the last
thing Bill said to him said no matter
what you can't take us you can't take a
sack and then I said to him don't forget
your check down which is a very
conservative route where you just dump
the ball off to the back and Bledsoe was
standing there he goes the hell with
that he goes just sling it you know and
just go ahead and sling it don't worry
about that the Rams had just tied the
game up
17-17 they went that they had all the
momentum
and they kicked the ball off we get
stuck in our own and deep in our own end
of the other field so
first play
where you come out they almost gets sack
he do a little dump off pass to jail
Redmond Jr gets some uh he gets some
yards
so second play
I think he hit Jr again so Jr on the
sideline he do a little move he gets out
of bounds and now
everybody on our sideline is feeling
good about myself like here we go
because we don't want to go to overtime
and you know how it is in momentum once
your team's got it momentum you know
it's tough to stop that rolling once
they have it so I mean it was probably
one of the greatest drives that there's
been in the Super Bowl history because
all the momentum was on the other side
with a relatively inexperienced
quarterback
and I honestly feel if that game hadn't
went to overtime I think the Rams would
have been a little bit of different
outcome okay we're on just on our side
of Midfield
okay we had three receivers on the right
one on the left all three receivers on
the right were all running end Cuts
they're all run ends at different levels
he hit the the first of the three the
inside guy of the three his name was
Troy brown one of my favorite players
who then ran out of bounds up the left
sideline and got us into field goal
range
when he kicked the ball I'm behind it so
I see it if anybody ever see the dude
that's running on the field when we won
the first Super Bowl high kick in the
stuff and doing this that's me because
I'm behind I see it I'm on the field I'm
still I'm like oh I'm gonna like oh
we won it just it's just I lose my mind
man it's just it's unbelievable in that
moment the feeling you just
so little Moses just just take over and
that was the greatest feeling I have
ever had
[Applause]
foreign
after his first Super Bowl win
I think that would have been
pretty terrific
I would love to be there
oh the after party after winning the
Super Bowl
so
Mr craft we uh
he he has it set out for us he has it
set out we go back to the hotel we go to
the party room it's champagne this beer
is caviar issue and all the players in
the family everybody in one big room and
everybody just had a blast I'm talking
about we had a blast into the weed
mornings other hours everybody
congratulating taking pictures within
Lombardi trophy just feeling good about
ourselves Like We are the champions of
the world
after we won Super Bowl 36 all of a
sudden he had all these girls chasing
them all these movie stars and because
they heard how close he and I were at
the time I would have agents for these
movie stars reaching out to me to see if
they could get to Tommy so I very up sat
him down said look it you didn't get
good looking overnight like all of a
sudden oh no no one wanted you now all
of a sudden you won a Super Bowl and
they think you're good looking so I was
making fun of them but in reality
letting them know be careful
be careful because you've gone from a
person that no one knew to Superstar
you know you got to be careful so that
was my advice to him off the field
[Applause]
bill belatick and the way he handles his
business the Patriot Way and the way Tom
Brady functioned not only as an athlete
but as a human being well the Patriot
Way is you know there's one phrase do
your job check your ego at the door
that's a simple way of telling you what
the Patriots are all about check your
ego at the door
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
I was one of the teammates that that
kind of started the Patriots way you
know we started winning but uh it's just
hard-nosed grinding knowing your
assignment as the phrase they do now
that the guy also is do your job meaning
just do your job don't worry about
trying to do nobody else job if you got
11 guys doing their job
that's the Patriots way and it's just
playing Fun sound fundamental football
mistake free
[Applause]
you got a lot of people
you know a lot of people in a
professional sports team that have big
egos
you have ownership bigger EOS you have
coaches who have big egos you got
players who have big egos
okay there's a lot of Egos and Bill
better than anyone I've ever seen
has been able to get everyone ejector he
goes at the door and make it all about
the team he cuts players that are really
good players he trades players that are
really good players because if it's the
best interest of the team and he's going
ahead and doing it that's because of the
locker room
see problem guys we used to say they
like to find that little group in the
locker room
where they could and moan about
you know every everything
but when you walk into that locker room
there was nowhere for them to go
so what would they do they'd convert
because that's what you do
and I think that Bill gets credit for
that for building that mentality that
good football teams the locker room
really controls you know what happens
with the players
Tom is always focused on his job
whatever his task is whether it's being
a dad whether it's being a quarterback
whether it's being a training for
football and in life he's always laser
focused and he's got inundability and an
incredible ability to focus on whatever
he's doing at the time in Excel at it
sometimes you got to fight your own way
through and that's exactly you know what
Tom proves you know all the way through
Michigan and then you know becoming what
he is today Tommy yeah there was always
better athletes than Tommy harder
workers no more heart no more
competition no those are the little
extra boxes that you check off when
you're playing he has a sensational
desire to
make himself better and make his team
better he never rests on the
accomplishment that he that he has right
now on the past he's always looking to
get the next ring the next win the next
championship well it's it's there's
nothing about last year and that's in
the past I mean we have a new experience
this year so
our future you know we've got to be able
to create our own future and um that's
really about attitude effort preparation
Tom is Tom is always motivated by Tom
you're too old Tom you're too slow Tom's
next game isn't against the opponent
it's against the critics
and the people who don't believe in Tom
and Tom's whole focus is I'm going to
shut these people up
you find somebody like that and you
still let them know you can't do it that
just adds even more you know gas into
the fire where we're just like oh you
think I can do it now I'm gonna go twice
as hard so it's like that certain people
you should not uh you know imitate them
[Music]
um
is Brady a practice monster
let me let me let me take my head off
for this one
it would be some times
after practice now remind you Brady he
started off as the Third Street
quarterback he moved his way up to the
second string and when Drew bledso got
hurt he became the first string
quarterback
and he will have us after practice
running routes catching balls come on
torn let's go with all the backs running
the routes and we'd be like God damn we
just practiced
four pass for two hours getting hit on
the rent all you did was throw the
quarterback you can't hit the
quarterback
but we beat up but he still wanted to go
out there in practice but
that was him
telling his crap and learning the game
and being a professional player that he
is today
just that drive to be the best that he
could be
[Music]
Tommy he truly plays the way that he
practice
in practice
he would talk at lawyer Malloy in
Thailand
because when he was younger coming in
you know what's coming in with blessed
they would tease him they would pick him
up throw it right here Brady and then
we'll fire him up that would make him so
mad and so when he would make a good
play against one of those against Tyler
lawyer somebody in practice or anybody
to give him a good throw people yeah
yeah that's it I told y'all I got this
and you know if that's the type of fiery
guy that Tommy is and it started truly
so what you see
he was doing that in practice so that
that is when he does in the game ain't
no pretending right there that that is
Tom Brady
I don't know
out of age Tom now but I'll give you an
example he was playing in one of those
little golf tournaments Tom was in the
parking lot before doing sprints and I
know this because my son-in-law was
there watching it and he's going
he left he did Sprints he played 18
holds and they went back to the parking
lot and did more Sprints because he had
practice coming up in a few days that in
itself is saying he's always doing
something and when he was here it was
always well I need to throw extra coach
stay extra hey coach I need to work on
my footwork he was he was very tough on
himself and and we may have won a game
but he didn't get a hit and it was hard
for him to accept that and just to get
him to to relax and understand how
important he was to us got to come show
up to work every day try to go out and
get our job done it's a um
you know today wasn't our best days I
guess I'm a little frustrated from that
we as running backs
been practicing all day you got passed
on you getting beat up you can beat to
the ground
and he want to play catch at the
practice and you like damn time man we
tired
oh we're trying to be crazy then all
that coming you'd be like one of them
days you'd be like man I don't want to
hear that today man I'm gonna go in I'm
tired but there here you go oh you okay
man
now we got to play catch with him
because now he didn't got mad and if we
didn't get married because we tired and
want to go in but he want to play catch
you know it's one thing if you know
we miss the past we catch a pass
you know I just I'm concerned that's you
know doing the things that we talked
about doing and executing them the right
way and then you know they're throwing
and catching and locking and tackling I
mean that's for the game you know it
doesn't let you catch every ball out
here you go in the game you drop it
doesn't matter it's you know you got to
work on the fundamentals out here work
on your communication you know we could
definitely do a much better job of that
and Tom by the way can be an
when he's playing Tom gets on guys when
they screw up he yells at him but they
love Tommy they love his teammate for
love him and it's the fifth string guys
in the Stars they all love them
[Music]
there's this level of accountability
when you have veteran guys like like Tom
around where you're you're not only
going to get it from the coaches but the
the veteran players as well just with
the expectations that they have for you
but he throws an incomplete pass he goes
nuts somebody runs the wrong route
he goes nuts
you know so when he throws an incomplete
pass he'll go nuts on himself now
it's just not nuts on other people but I
mean if somebody runs the wrong Brown
they'll say what are you doing I said in
in he's like another coach on the field
but in practice
he's he's a as competitive in practice
as he is in the games
I don't know if you've ever watched the
movie Groundhog Day
with Bill Murray where he wakes up every
day
is the same day
that's what practices would every day is
the same so let's just say it's a
Wednesday
just a Wednesday so on Wednesday morning
I'm going to give me leading into him
because I always used to have to be
prepared before he got there so I'd be
ready to go at 5am my assistant coach
that would help with the quarterbacks
would meet with me at six a.m at 6 30
every day he would come Tommy would come
in alone go over all the new
installation that was going in that we
had prepared the night before
seven o'clock the rest of the
quarterbacks would come in and we'd do
it all over again we'd go over that
installation all over again then eight
o'clock he would meet with all the
skilled people all the wide receivers
the tight ends and the running backs and
go over the passes for the day okay
before we even install them so that the
players had a heads up then we'd have a
team meeting and then we'd get going
going with meetings get going with
practice now your practice is over okay
now you meet with the players you go
over the videotape from that day and
then they would be done with the coaches
because now the coaches had to start
preparing for the next day
he doesn't like missing practice Tommy
does not like missing practice enemies
missing practice it's just to save his
body it has nothing to do he likes
practice you know because he he always
felt when we always felt as an
organization
that you know when you're going to
practice you're going to play like your
practice
and that I think that's one of the
reasons why our team won so much is
because we practice so hard
people say Michael Jordan they say Kobe
number was arrogant and cocky but you
earn it with your plate you earn that
respect
if you're not that good people wouldn't
say that you would cocky and say that
you operate but see you earned it
through your plate
see he's the most hated quarterback why
because he's the best quarterback
to me
he done more with less Talent around him
than any other quarterback as far as at
the wide receiver position if you are
being disliked by people
then you have to earn that and he he
earned all the hate that he gets he
earned it because he is the most
successful guy it's it's it's tough to
be as successful as Tom Brady and being
liked by everybody that's just not the
case
foreign
if you if you look at him and you see
some some of the stuff that goes on on
the sideline where he gets into it with
Josh McDaniel his offense coordinator
you know he's very competitive and and
he will let you know if he's not happy
with anything and that rubs people the
wrong way but ultimately that's exactly
how you want a professional successful
athlete to be but you know not everybody
understands that and uh and I understand
that fans look at him and say well he's
he's too cocky he's too arrogant well
yeah that might be the case but you have
to have that certain Edge to be the best
way
let's go every time you succeed
people will hate
and this man a lot of success so there
is a
correlation between hating success no
matter how good you are no matter how
great no matter how much you perform
that's always somebody who doesn't like
what you do there's always somebody who
thinks somebody else could do better
than you Tom Tom's focuses on winning
the next game doesn't care what people's
opinion are does not care
unless they're in a decision-making
the position involving Tom he doesn't
care about stuff like that and that's
why that's why I really
like him because he just comes in here
and gets out there
[Music]
thank you
Gronkowski's managed to be sort of the
frat boy the party animal without
getting in trouble which is that's
pretty impressive because almost anybody
who who flies as Loose as Rob Gronkowski
does they tend to get into trouble and I
I can't think of of any troubles that
Rob's gotten into with the law he seems
to know where the line is that's
difficult if you're out there you know
partying a lot
congratulations thank you I appreciate
it
[Music]
oh my gosh
[Applause]
[Music]
I think it's probably the brand that
comes with the jersey and the brand that
comes with the individual I think the
Tom Brady brand is a different brand
than the Gronk brand the big Gronk
the party grung I I can I can see why
people would rather associate with a
partying six seven 245 dude then a 44
year old
quarterback who has been playing that
game for for 30 50 60 years
you know Tom Brady is not famous for
being a fancy good-looking guy well he
is good looking he's got a gorgeous wife
too but he is not the Swagger type of
fashion guy like Cam Newton is or plus
he he is a different generation he's
more the old school throwback
quarterback from the early 2000s he is
not a pat Mahomes or Lamar Jackson with
this Oakleys on that's not Tom Brady the
good thing is he doesn't need to sell
one single t-shirt anyway because I
think he's pretty wealthy
I think he um
patting this game by the Joe Montana I
think
him winning Seven Super Bowls being
um
arguably the best quarterback to ever
play The National Football League but
you'll have some people that say Joe
Montana
and and I truly think he wants to be
up there by himself I think Brady wants
to be up there on the mountain by
himself you have to have that that
certain that certain Edge to yourself
and obviously people some people don't
like that but ultimately he wins and
that's what Madison pro football
this year down 25 points I mean it's
hard to imagine us winning but
it took a lot of great plays and um
that's why you play to the end it's 60
Minute game and you know halftime I'd
say we were we were we weren't down at
all I mean we were disappointed in the
way we played and knew that we could go
out and do a lot better in the second
half so he's down 28-3 and he wins 34-28
I remember watching that game
when he was down and the announcers even
were starting to write them off and I
thought I don't know that he's going to
win this game but he's going to make a
game of it that's how good he is you're
confident the guy's down by
25 points in the second half and you
still think it's Tom Brady he's the only
guy maybe in the history of football
that when he's down by that much in the
second half of her game you think it's
not over it's not completely over he's
like a coach's nightmare every every
coach is paranoid
and until like you know they're they're
up by 17 points with two minutes to go
and football coaches still feel there's
some way they can lose the game
but but Tom Brady is is I think part of
the reason for that nightmare that they
they think maybe this guy is going to be
Tom Brady today maybe somebody's going
to do what Tom Brady does and find a way
to beat us and that's what Tom does you
know the losses in this game are tough I
mean you're going to live with those for
the rest of your life
and uh those will be games if you lose
there's regrets about every play in that
game so you know when you win you don't
think about any of those things there's
no regrets so you just gotta try to uh
you know
put everything aside so you can have
your best performance on Sunday night
that's uh that's what we're gonna
remember most about this week is the
game and uh
you know that's that's really what I
want to get to be focused on as well
a lot of stuff that goes on in the media
really has nothing to do with what's
going on inside the locker room inside
the locker room we are worried about the
next game the next opponent what we can
improve on from the week before that the
reality of the NFL is that every year
the deck of cards get shuffled and
somebody that you were just playing with
is on a different team you don't know if
you're going to be here you don't you'll
know if there's going to be a tomorrow
for you it doesn't matter who you are it
doesn't matter if you're the best player
at your position
um I just think it was time you know if
you see this a lot in professional
sports sometimes that's what happens and
you know you saw the same thing with Joe
Montana at the end of the career they
want to bring in younger fresher people
and Tom wasn't done playing so made the
trip on over to Tampa
foreign
as far as I know they split on good
terms you know the Press sometimes can
add a few things here from what I heard
but it was definitely a good split and
everyone left peacefully and now
everyone's moving on and Tommy's happier
the Patriots letting him go
199th picking the draft the Brady six
the six guys dropped that ahead in he
remembers all of it and that fuels him
the bust is your head so
obviously time he played there 20 years
he had he won sixer walls there it's not
going to change just because Bill
Belichick doesn't think he can play
anymore
I don't really know what that was all
about to be honest with you I think that
Tom wanted something different you've
been there a long time
um probably got a little tired of the
New England weather
as far as I feel I think he wanted to
change and I think he wanted just to
show that he can do what he did
now they're becoming too confrontational
to each other they were starting to butt
heads and with the media and everything
else
who was really bringing the
Championships who was bringing all the
fame to the Patriots and they both have
egos and I think it was just a parting
of ways Bill Belichick wanted Garoppolo
uh wanted someone else instead of Tommy
to show that hey I my system works with
anybody I think Tom took offense to it
Tom goes well you know what my
contract's up I'm gonna go let me find
the right area Tampa Bay we're going to
build a winner there
I mean you know those are two guys maybe
who found theirselves like who just
Belong Together Like a Rock Band
they were together and they were super
successful and when they split you see
okay who who still has it
yeah I feel I feel really good it's been
you know again it's the first time in
14 years I haven't had to wear a knee
sleeve I mean every
picture I've had since for 14 years has
been a knee sleeve and in games I'll
still wearing knee brace just because I
still want to protect
um you know from kind of a vulnerable
vulnerable spot for a quarterback you
know your front left knee but um
it's just nice to practice and feel like
I can just kind of put a pair of shorts
on and run out to practice and uh it's
good though I'm feeling like I said
physically feeling great mentally in a
good place
[Music]
a player at the age of 30 might be older
in terms of Orthopedic structures but it
has a lot more experience to see
situations where he can avoid and to to
play the game more economic than the
younger player does being at the age of
43 is not a prerequisite to get overuse
injuries it depends on your state of
training and depends on your physical
state so there's many players that get
overused injuries at the age of 18 and
there is many players that get over his
injuries at the end of 25.
so an overused injury depends on several
factors and that's how you perform your
sports how do you move how economic do
you move how well trained is your body
and so forth
I saw that he's doing things differently
with his nutrition you know he would
have his meals prepared and always eat
something that looked very healthy you
know well we might be over here taking
advantage of fat Friday and eating some
burgers or eating some pizza you know he
would always stick to his regiment and
just be super disciplined about
everything right there's no you don't
get into tb12 thing when he was young he
drank beer and ate pizza too just like
everybody else no the man eating avocado
ice cream for God's sakes who in the
hell eats avocado ice cream if I want
some ice cream I want some real ice
cream but that's what it comes to in
sports is uh you'll spend a million
dollars a year on taking care of your
body
Tom's TV 12 method with the pliability
that's showing you a different way where
you can last a lot longer in sports
without all the rehabilitation without
the drugs without that and so he's been
able to do his whole career and last
this long without any of that so you
know it's the stretching the pliability
keeping your muscles nice and loose all
the time to prevent injury that's what's
always worked for him and I think that's
amazing I I would definitely pass that
on to my football players you know as
they go through in their careers but I
love that he's standing for that and
showing natural ways to take care of
yourself other than the ways that a lot
of us know and what Tom always believed
in the tb12 is my muscles have to be
more Supple if I'm going to play to a
longer age if I'm going to play through
injuries my muscles can't be all tight
rigid they have to be more fluid
the tb12 method will not change the way
this board's played the owners are
worried about
Cash Money Talks pre-season games make
money more I can do the better more
times I can put the product in front of
the people the better the players on the
other hand are saying hey you already
know who your stars are we need more
recovery time and more game time we
don't need all that pre-season stuff
that's great for the rookies
but now the older guys more seasoned
guys people who've been around for a
while
they're the ones that are saying hey no
we need more time off
years and years ago I saw in Sport
magazine which doesn't even exist
anymore a survey and they asked
Olympic athletes if you could win a gold
medal but you knew that you it would
cost you to the point where you would be
dead in five years would you make that
Pact
the majority of them in this poll said
yes
oh my goodness that just tells you
how desperate people are to be Champions
and how and and I think maybe they think
that wouldn't really happen so that you
know unless you're going to be held to
it you know you're not getting it
completely truthful answer but it amazes
me that anybody would put their health
on the line especially
their life and death Health on the line
the bottom line is in the NFL your job
is there to be taken and I think that's
the fear that motivates more than
anything if I don't play Hurt
they'll get somebody else who will play
and also play her
Okay the reason why they protect the
quarterbacks
you know with the rules is because
they're getting paid the most amount of
money
so if you have a guy who's making 30
million dollars I mean do you want that
guy hurt and sitting you know in a
medical tent or you want him on the
field
all those people in the stands are
paying the money to come watch him play
so that's why the rules protect the
quarterbacks if he goes down nine times
out of ten
team going down so you cannot hit the
quarterback in practice you cannot even
get close to the quarterback in practice
if you think you're getting close to the
quarterback in practice stop
because you will get a tongue Lesson by
the coach
if I met Tom Brady today
I'd have a big smile on my face I'd give
them a hug
say he's
been a great influence on my family my
friends and then he would look at me and
he'd say what happened to you used to be
so thin
when I saw him two years ago three years
ago in Boston it's exactly what he said
there he goes coach I've probably gained
40 pounds since then he goes what
happened I go hey I got older and two
the tb12 system doesn't work
I mean this game is about winning
I mean you know we can give stats for
all sorts of people and he's going to
end up having all the stats too
but I mean this game's about winning
he is part of the reason why the
Patriots are the Patriots but afterwards
when Tom Brady left the team and went to
Tampa Bay he won the Super Bowl ring
when I heard that he would be a free
agent at the end of the year
I knew he wouldn't be there anymore
because how does a guy who's
been that much been that important
you know for your organization how are
they free how they not contractually
bound to being with you and you know
whether Tommy wanted out or whether Bill
wanted to go is really a moot point you
know the point is that he was free and
he went somewhere where he thought he
had a better chance of winning the Super
Bowl
and how'd that work out
[Music]
congratulations to the Bucks it's been a
long time coming man y'all made this
through the night and uh hey we Champs
great it was amazing watching the Bucks
win a Super Bowl
this is great for Tampa Bay Area Brady
is like a savior for Tampa we need him
thank God Brady go Bucks yeah we spent a
lot of money to come down here see our
favorite team and favorite player
Patrick Mahomes and it was uh
disappointing we got shocked Tom Brady's
the goat what are you gonna do well when
he went to the Buccaneers they were the
worst organization in the NFL since
1976.
and he won a Super Bowl in a covid
season and beat the new Golden Boy the
NFL battles
there was the game where they lost and
he threw a couple of picks and he threw
a pick because it was a miscommunication
receiver I said
yo you gotta understand
he is using this now
to get himself right and get to know all
these players because if the chemistry
is right he gonna do it I knew it
and then he won the Super Bowl
[Applause]
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers managed to keep
all 22 starters on offense and on
defense
he's got the same group of guys around
him and you can bet that Tom Brady is
going to keep them motivated and he's
probably already talking about Hey
Nobody's Gonna expect us to repeat so
let's show it to everybody that we can
repeat and let's you know create a
history here in Tampa and do something
that was never been done in Tampa so I
think there's a good chance for him to
host the trophy again in 2022.
thank you
[Music]
his leadership
so different
and I think he if you get to the
playoffs and have somebody like him your
confidence boosts so high that you
automatically play at your best level
did you see how the defense played the
Super Bowl
what
presence is so great and I think having
him on the team is like if you play
Madden and you you play Ultimate Team
and you have these cards that have like
you can boost and he's like an absolute
booster
[Music]
yeah
the funniest thing that I've ever seen
Tom Brady do was after they won the last
Super Bowl and they had a boat parade in
Tampa down the Hillsborough River it's a
nice warm day the players had their
shirts off they were horsing around
they're having a good time they were
probably having a beer or two and
everything's going along and and
everybody's waving and everybody's happy
and then Tom Brady decides
to underhand Chuck the Super Bowl trophy
to the boat behind him
and one of the receivers there catches
it and when you're watching them do this
you're thinking this is insane the Super
Bowl trophy is going to go glug glug
glug to the bottom of the river but he
completed that pass too but it was it
was a moment where I mean I thought it
was staged but Tom Brady did it and it
was it was good for some laughs that's
for sure
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what how long Tom Brady will
play is the million dollar question
if he loses
no because he'll want to come back and
win
if he wins no because he wants a show
that he can do it a third time so will
it be his last season no he will come
back no matter what with vengeance Tom
it's uh it's 103 degrees out here won
seven Super Bowls yeah I still feel uh
comfortable with your decision to come
back like why do you keep putting
yourself through this well it's I mean
it's really fun for me to
you know it's it's very fun I love
physically to train it to put myself in
a position to compete
um you know I love the mental aspect of
the sport and um I have a lot of fun
doing it it's a lot of joy in my life so
but I gotta gotta keep earning it you
know I don't think it's any aspect of me
that thinks what I've done last year
means anything I got to go do it this
year going from there and having that
mindset to keep going and then win a
Super Bowl and win another another in
another and then win another one then go
to bucks and win another one within a
year with a new team I think there's a
lot of learn from that man
I think Tom Brady is playing only three
more years to the max
he can't be playing 250. he said I don't
want to say old man but win another ring
and then
and call it call it call it before he
retires
yes without a question he'll win another
Super Bowl Tom will get to eight
minimum
Tom win another Circle
[Applause]
well what would I tell Tommy when I see
him next
first thing I'm gonna tell him I'm gonna
congratulate him on winning this seventh
Super Bowl
telling that I love him
and we started that dynasty in New
England
I think because I think that it's
something big that we can learn not for
only for sports but for life in general
to focus on on what is possible and not
all the things all the odds that are
against us I would totally uh agree with
my kids taking Tom Brady as a role model
from a guy that was not drafted very
high was drafted very late to then rise
up and become you know the biggest
person in the game
[Applause]
today's Tom Brady
I think
you know he don't get no pushback you
talking to a man that has one seven
Super Bowls been to 10. what can you
push back on him about
you trying to learn from the best
oh there's no way Tom Brady is going to
be a football coach it might come a
president become a president his
aspirations are a lot higher than being
a football coach I see him being a CEO
of a company but he does like politics
so it would not Shock Me And to be
honest with you right now if he ran he'd
probably have a chance of winning
somebody for president has a good ring
to it but I think too many people hate
Tom Brady if it's as much as they like
him
[Applause]
he's the most hated quarterback
because he's the best quarterback
Tom Brady never looked back he's got an
incredible ability to focus on whatever
he's doing at the time
he took it upon himself to work really
hard just that drive to be the best that
he could be
Tom Brady's a winner he will come back
no matter what
[Music]
my favorite story about Tom Brady is
definitely his answer to the question
what is your favorite Super Bowl ring
and he said
the next
play by itself
[Music]
break
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm enough